في السودان جدلا واسع اثرته فتوى رئيس
لجنه الاحوال الشخصيه في مجمع الفقه
الاسلامي علاء الدين ابو زيد ابو زيد
اجازه للرجل الزواج من زوجه اخرى دون ان
يخبر زوجته او اسرته مشتركه توفر الشروط
بحضور الشهود في الزواج التصريحات نقلتها
مواقع ووسائل اعلام بشكل كبير في الاوساط
السودانيه وتفاعل معها رواد مواقع التواصل
وشخصيات مجتمعيه معروفه مؤكدين ان المراه
السودانيه ترفض ذلك وبشده كما تزامن
التصريحات وهو ربما ما اثار الموضوع بشكل
اكبر مع تقرير صحيفه الانتباه السودانيه
كشف عن تفشي ظاهره الزواج السري بشكل كبير
خلال الفتره الماضيه في السودان خوفا
الاولى
[موسيقى]
ما رايك اولا في هذه الفتوى زواج الزوج من
دون علم زوجته
رايي طبعا انا ضد الفكره تماما لان هي
بتهديم الفكره الاساسيه للزواج اللي هي
المفروض يكون مبني على حسن المعشر والصدق
والامانه والحب والتفاهم
وعقد الزواج هو ما وصفه سبحانه وتعالى
بالمثال
يكون الزواج السردي وهو يعني يعتمد على
صفات المنافق الثلاثه اذا تحدث كذب واذا
وعد
كل ما يتزوج زواج سريع يعتمد على الثلاثه
هي الكذب والخلف في الوعد والخيانه يعني
نحن ضد الفكره تمام واذا في رجل اصلا اراد
ان يتزوج باخرى فليقكم بالشجاعه بمكان في
انه هو يحدث الزوجه الاولى ويصارحه ويرتب
وضعها كما تريد وتعلم ثم ذلك همم
شيخ اسامه يعني الامر بالاساس وكانه مبني
على خطا مبني على سر مبني على عدم اشهار
بالتالي كيف تنظرون الى هذه المساله التي
اصبحت متفشيه نوعا ما في السودان
يعني انا لست متحدثا باسم مجمع الفقه
الاسلامي وانا ك داعيه وباحث في الشؤون
الاجتماعيه
كاحد تلاميذ الدكتور علاء الدين عبد الله
ابو زيد الامين العام لجمعيه الامام مالك
الفقيه هي هذه التي صرح بها عبر السوشيال
ميديا
لم تكن فتوى صادره من مجمع الفقه الاسلامي
اولا
ثانيا لم يفتي بها الدكتور علاء الدين عبد
الله ابو زيد انما هي يعني انا لا اريد ان
اقول عدم مهنيه او اقول كذبه يعني روجت
عبر الوسائط واريد بها يعني تشويه صوره
الدكتور او هنا او ما الى ذلك همم الامر
حدث في انه رجل استفتاء الدكتور على دين
عبد الله ابو زيد وهو رجل مالك ونحن هنا
في السودان مالكيه همم الزواج السر نحن
المالكيه وكل الساده المالكيه المتاخرين
والمتقدمين لا يجيزون زواج السر بل يقولون
بفسخه
بفسخه يفسخون هذا الزواج حتى اذا اشترط
الرجل على الشهود او اذا اشترط على همم
يعني ولي الزاويه الثانيه ان يكون هذا
الزواج السريا فانه يفسخ عندنا ومن شروط
الزواج وصحه الزواج وسلامه الزواج ان يكون
معلنا وان يكون يعني الجميع يعرف هذا
الزواج وكما ذكرت الاستاذه اميره هذا
ميثاق غليظ وهو سدل الزرائع اذا كانت
هنالك احدى الفتيات ضبطت في مساله غير
شرعيه او حبله
بغير شرعي حبل غير شرعي همم لربما يعني
تتوانى او تقول والله قد تزوجت من ثلاث
فهذه سريعه من الزرائع قد سدتها شريعتنا
السمحه فلم تكون هذه فتوى باي حال من
الاحوال نحن نقول ان الزواج يجب ان يكون
باركانه وان يكون بولين وان لا تزود
المراه كما قال النبي صلى الله عليه واله
وسلم اي امراه نكحت من غير ولي همم زواجها
باطل